nora i'm so honored to co-pilot today's
edition of drew's news where we serve
the stories
thanks guys okay nora please kick us off
okay on it all right time magazine just
announced
their kid of the year this is new cover
and the honor goes to gatanjali rau
of lone tree california she's 15
already invented a device that can
detect lead contamination in water
coded an app that uses artificial
intelligence to flag
cyberbullies and apparently you can read
all about it in time magazine she said
you just need to be passionate
about one thing and try and solve it and
i was not doing anything near that cool
when i was 15. but were you i was
no i was kind of a burner at 15 but i
i by 19 i started my own business flower
film
so you know i wasn't saving the world
but i was trying to
make joy you in it you were more
precocious than the rest of us
i was born with like a martini and like
let's do this you know i already feel 60
and 70 years old now but
it's good to get a jump start but what
she did is so profound and angelina
jolie did the interview which is really
exciting to read
okay in huge news for the movie business
the place that i
turned to to have a very stable job and
career the wall street journal reports
that warner brothers
will release all their 2021 movies in
theaters
but more importantly on hbo max
simultaneously
they're kicking it off with wonder woman
1984 on christmas day
and they've got 17 large ticket item
movies linwell
manuel miranda's in the heights the
star-studded dunes space jam
2 with lebron and matrix 4. and
the movies will spend a month on hbo max
and they'll
be in theaters possibly i think it's
going to be a
let's see what happens with covid and
movie openings but
i think what this means is not only is
this just
jaw-dropping bombshell hollywood news
but i think it's now nice to know we can
rest
for 2021 this is what will be happening
because this whole
keep pushing movies thing and theaters
and you know
the business it was just too crazy and
too much they've made a decision
this is going to change the landscape
for the year i do have hope for theaters
um you know in the future but i'm glad
that they made such a big bold call for
right now
you're so right it's huge you know our
company paramount plus is doing the same
kind of thing in 2021
but i have to say i feel sad i miss the
movie theaters and sort of nostalgic
about it i mean
where was the place you went when you
were 15 or 16 on your first date maybe
you had your first makeout you know i
mean the
theaters were like the place to go so i
do hope once everybody gets
vaccinated they'll be back in business
and paramount has cbs all access to turn
to they already have a really successful
platform
um so i'm interested to see what their
move will be
okay and finally in shoe news um the new
air jordans
actually just launched and they are
automatic lacing as in you have an app
on your phone
and they will do the lacing for your
preset
satisfactory mode and i mean this is
just so crazy here we are this is the
future it's very marty mcfly
and um in shoe news we have one last
headline for the road and it's one
i'm really proud of because we're
teaming up with payless for a special
give back this holiday
um they're gonna donate 6 000 pairs of
shoes
and um we'll roll into the clip but
before we do
nora i just want to say it has been an
honor and a realized dream of a lifetime
to co-anchor some news and i would love
to do this anytime
anywhere with you thank you oh my
goodness well thank you love drew's news
[Music]
you